Speaker 1: Well, as many of you know, every two
or three months we have a last minute cancellation
or a no show or a problem with a guest. And it's
unfortunate, but it is impossible to prevent 100%
when that happens. I say let's hear from a few
people in the audience, so let's do that. Now,
of course, we take calls via discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's start with
Mitchell from Ohio. Mitchell, what's on
your mind today? What can I do for you?
Speaker 3: Hi, David. I've been thinking
a lot recently about how most people on
opposite sides of the political spectrum
have more in common with each other than
they will ever have with people who have a vast
amount of influence and power in this country.
True. And I just can't seem to wrap my head
around how we get people to understand that
their interests are more aligned than they think.
Speaker 1: I don't know the answer to that either.
And you know what? The first time that this was
like, very evident to me was that in a movement
I covered closely. It was the 2010, the growth
of the Tea Party movement. And Jonathan Haidt has
written a lot about this, where a lot of it has
to do with you're not thinking in terms of what
is actually best for me. And the vast majority
of people, including people who supposedly are
on the opposite political side. You're thinking
in terms of my team, you're thinking in terms
of the people who I sort of take direction
from. What are they telling me to do? What
are they saying is best? And I genuinely don't
know. A lot of this has very deep psychology
written into it, as Jonathan Haidt has written
about. And I don't because you're absolutely right
on so many issues, particularly economic issues,
even if we put aside social issue differences,
the vast majority of Americans actually
have the same interests and would benefit
from the same policies, and yet they
are split between two political parties.
Speaker 3: I'd have to agree with you. And if you
ask anyone from either party or either side of
the aisle, I feel like most people just want to be
able to put in an honest day's work for an honest
day's wage, come home to their family and do it
again the next day and put a little money aside.
But do you think that there's truth to that? There
is an artificial culture war being started by,
you know, people like Ron DeSantis to try
and stop people from seeing the economic
issues that they actually have in common.
Speaker 1: That's one way to put it. The way
and I don't think you're wrong the way I've
said it is a little different, which is the
country keeps moving left on policy, particularly
economic policy. So what the right has done is
abandoned policy, particularly economic policy,
and do the culture war. So I don't know that it's
overtly to prevent people from realizing that's
an interesting perspective. But I think it's
basically if it was just about policy, Republicans
would have an even tougher time winning elections.
So when they make it about something else instead.
But it's basically the same thing you're saying.
Speaker 3: And it's all it's all very
interesting. And I appreciate your
perspective. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, Mitchell from Ohio,
very important and well-said. I appreciate that.